une production du studio sf salut tout
le monde
aujourd'hui le podcast est commandité
par vive smoothie rice mutti c'est super
simple cd petit cube comme se claque
congelés mais ça n'a t-on shaker dans
ton pour ma son trait tout en liquide du
bros et le tour est joué
c'est merveilleux c'est délicieux pas
besoin de mélangeurs c'est bio c'est
local c'est super santé la protéine et
végétales donc cv gagnent également en
ont maintenant trois saveurs des
protéines végétales toutes délicieuses
les unes que les autres
on a un code promo va les chercher si
qui en fait c est vive protéines 2 et
avec ceux à avoir un petit bonus sur
votre 1ere commande c'est jusqu'au 29
février cette offre le et vous allez
avoir un chez que et de smoothie
supplémentaires sur commande n'est ce
pas merveilleux
alors aller chercher ceux comme je vous
dis c'est santé c'est bon pour commencer
la journée un petit souci à vivre rien
de mieux
alors je prenne ce berger pour vous oye
oye
bienvenue au sans fil ultra le podcast
où on parle de ce qu'on veut avec nos
invités au dessus je suis h quand un
avec moins de plantes
cette semaine le sans filtre et présenté
par v gagnent les pop up vegan n'est pas
plate c'est mon entreprise c'est une
compagnie québécoise avec des fondateurs
québécois qui viennent d'ici basée à
yverdon en fait c'est une compagnie de
de nourriture fihri c'est une compagnie
dans le fond on offre des recettes vegan
on un livre de recettes qui s'appelle
vegan mais pas plate on a un site web
des gardes ne peut plus être points
comme on a une page facebook jesse et ph
qui rêvait mpp pour vegan n'est pas
plate c'est vraiment un 360 puisqu'on
parle de véganisme un sujet qui nous
importe énormément et où est-ce qu'on
non seulement on parle des enjeux du
véganisme et on propose aussi des
réelles alternatives donc des recettes
des idées de dettes qui sont respectueux
des animaux de l'environnement des
façons de vivre notre vie qui sont éco
responsable et bénéfique à tous et à
toutes
donc allez voir surveillance n'est pas
plate point com puis si vous écoutez le
podcast avec bob le chef j'imagine que
la nourriture vous intéresse vous savez
sans doute faut réduire notre
consommation de viande pour
l'environnement donc allé voir les
recettes surveillants mais pas par
points comme vous ne serez pas déçus et
on a aussi un livre de recettes que me
dit tout à l'heure et on a un deuxième
qui sent bien qu'ils aient dans le four
donc c'est ça allait voir ce pauvre et
c'est vrai que yes également
commanditaire du podcast le studio sf ce
magnifique studio dans lequel on
enregistre une podcast mais pas
seulement nous ajuster pas castille si
n'importe qui peut enregistrer son
podcast suffit nous écrire dans le fond
on loue le studio avec tout ce que ça
implique comme technique autant micro
caméra que l'école ici et nicoletta
ambiance et notre pub à nous fait qu'on
se garde pour faire ce qu'on veut et
perd aucun annonceur cannondale à ce
n'est pas cool ça gueulait ceni calquer
nichols et les techniciens le plus la
coche que j'ai jamais été tellement bon
michael c'est un nom du bon travail pour
vrai cette épaule pas avec nous il ya un
grand manque de vie de ces personnes
c'est l'âme de tristesse aux chemical
station pour la bonne cause on le traite
bien une école il mange bien et se
nourrit bien fait que ça vient que tout
ça écrivez nous à sans filtre podcast
commercial gmail.com qui se tient on va
discuter de projets pouvez passer votre
propre podcasts ou face que vous voulez
nationale france on ne regarde plus
rendu là nicole by opi va regarder et à
sinon cette semaine d'homme on a reçu
bob le chef 1
chef chef chef politique et pauvres est
un gars tellement drôle
on aurait pu faire un pataquès de 6 ans
je pense qu'il ya eu des histoires
encore un gars qui travaille dans le
milieu de la restauration battant qui
est tant que chef entre autre des restes
europe
et puis après ça il ya décider de cela
c'est un peu en affaire tellement partir
son propre reine bob le chef les livres
de laisser l'anarchie culinaire selon
bob le chef moi c'est le premier livre
que j'ai eu le premier livre de recettes
que j'ai eu ma larme à acheter sur
l'anarchie culinaire un de trop
bobst une légende est littéralement une
légende il fait des faits des vidéos et
fédérer si tu voulais trouver en ligne
il fait toutes sortes d'affaires ils se
parlent et font ensuite réseaux sociaux
cliquez le bob le chef puis c'est drôle
on a parlé un petit peu notre podcast
mais bob lille est un personnage dans un
roman dans un livre s'appelle le
plongeur de ses fans à lui j'en parle
parce qu'on a brièvement parlé dans le
podcast by depuis qu'on le tourne et
j'ai finalement lu le roman mais
tellement drôle dé lire steve loeb
quitte neuvre qui est un peu de l'auto
fiction l'auteur en fait il raconte son
période sa jeunesse où il était plongé
dans deux restaurants et un des employés
de restaurant en cuisine
c'était baup la manière qui décrit dans
le roman dans le livre c'est exactement
le bob que vous allez voir devant nous
qui raconte des histoires qui est drôle
qui est fin qui est tandis que ce ton
meilleur ami puis un bon segway en fait
avec youtube ender si vous voulez nous
entendre parler du plongeur plus en
profondeur on a fait un podcast de mai
mois ensemble exclusif à nos membres
pétrone donc vêtu en fait une plateforme
ce que vous pouvez nous encourager sur
une plateforme as com et les podcasts au
moment où est-ce qu'ils sont tournés en
ce moment on a en plus de toutes les
pièces qu'ils sont disposés sur la
chaîne en un podcast avec 4 bastien on
un podcast avec mehdi moussaïd anne qui
sont disponibles sur le pétrole et on va
faire des papiers comme ça où est-ce
qu'on traite justement de trucs qui se
passent dans nos vies dont la lecture du
plongeur donc allé voir notre page pu
tuer le lien il va être dans la
description on va des podcasts ou on
parle de ce qu'on veut
on nous l'a dit exact donc sans plus
attendre on vous laisse avec cette
conversation là avec la légende qui est
bob le chef bon paquet afone
[Musique]
ces retrouvailles pour quelqu'un qui
coûtait pas trop moi c'est ça tu faisais
une recette de ré je suis né de l'arrêt
avec richard sur youtube
ça durait deux heures tout le monde
c'était juste des jardins john beck
abord celle face à ces faits précis
lanta risque accru ses parts dans les
bacs le chef live le gekkan marée était
un plus de fait l'an passé on a fait
souvent la 4e temps mais c'est aussi ce
sont des bus de 4,1 pouces qui m'a jetée
joyal universités début ben c'est sur la
table des charmes de longue date comme
je disais avant l'émission
au départ de l'étape sur 33mag point tv
qui était la première web tv du québec
puis c'était quand même pionniers à
l'époque le v3 émission il y avait vox
pop qui était
si ta base qu'on connaît une laurence
marais qui fait beaucoup de vidéo à
c't'heure kaki bien connu dans le monde
qui faisait son émission vox pop y avait
black taboo avec mange bien et tout ça
n'existe plus nulle part sur le web sont
les singles impossible de retrouver ce
impossible et il survécut sais tu suces
chrétiens sur tout le monde s'en
rappelle
en ce moment il ya des jeunes qui ont 15
heures qui dit cette blague mais qui ont
qu'une de bien même
même bernard adamus qui dans death
étonné dit que la vie asus quand
création c'est sa vie un peu de black
taboo bernard tabou dans chacun d'eux
ils ont quand même captivé l'imaginaire
du gène secondaires qu'on gorda qu'on
était on trouvait ça bien drôle à
l'époque des choses quand ils vont à
mathon à dolbeau à québec au dail c'est
encore plus ses malades plus du monde
proteste en avant doit absolument
absolument ce train de picoler si la
banque savait la vraie vie de vincent
courtemanche et richard je vais réussir
mais moi je peux pas dire ce qu'il fait
dans la vie mais c'est complètement
l'opposé aux gens notre peau que c'est
des personnages qui ont joué la blague
est oui
à trèbes a annoncé en outre c'est c'est
quand même un moment que tu as commencé
à faire la marche riner initialement à
un délai parce que j
mais j'étais cuisinier par un très jeune
j'ai commencé à 14 puis à 26 ans j'ai 30
ans je n'ai jamais pensé c'était pas que
l'on parle de gens 98-99 autour de deux
puits écoute j'ai comme la restauration
26 ans parce que je t'ai écrit ça
faisait 12 5 je faisais juste dans ma
vie au départ un monde et je trouvais
que ça va leur réserve juillet 21 22 h
les premiers matches amicaux mais comme
un job cet arrêt à montréal à l'époque
de la gratification si à l'intérieur
d'une cuisine n'était quand tu es tu
monte les échelons
c'est facile c'est facile et c'est
comment je peux dire emporté par la
clientèle c'est ce que tu as mangé tig
est dépensé 14 mai le pire jambes mais
c'est ces affaires là pis ça peut
facilement
ça peut facilement d'exister quand tu es
jaloux et stimuler puis mais à 26 ans
toutes mes jobs commence avec des vrais
jobs devrait déjà perdre que tous les
week-ends de conjugue pas aller camper
puis plus moche tu as tout le temps tout
un clou et au resto rapide remontée je
voyais pas ça comme je veux tu juste
fois et ce jusqu à 40 mg côté des
documentaires des chefs qui tamisent
dallas n'est pas que j'aime phoques et
40 ans puise encore du travail senteurs
semaine j'aimerais seulement n'ai pu
travailler le logis d'énergie plus à
faire mais je commence à moins de la
voix
puis je me suis ramassée dans les
restaurants qui s'appelle le mit stocker
le mr écoute c'est ça ta cam ou des
cuisiniers des bons cuisiniers à lèvres
comme ça comme un camp de vacances c'est
d'annoncer que c'est c'est un restaurant
un type tête avait une oreille de 35 à
40 heures semaine
le basket est un débile léger super bon
gars mais facilement négocié avec des
écoutes moi je vais à l'université je
reprends des cohabitations mon but c'est
travailler là elle à l'université je
loge de devenir prof puis puis au mr
j'ai rencontré toutes sortes de mon base
il y avait d'ailleurs c'était fin de la
gloire écrit deux plongeurs quitte à
plonger les meilleurs plongeurs se passe
dans un restaurant fictionnel qui publie
pas cliquer sur le misto exactement
personnage s'appelle le bob dans la baie
pis et ça ça a commencé là on a commencé
juste parler d'eux un espèce de délais
plus longs et exposants comme dix
personnes qui tarissent chaud puis
finalement bg comme choisi manque puis
jeté avec john de skateboard puis au
travail tout ça
c'est le monde serait encore avec
aujourd'hui alex et mathilde et là on
s'est donné comme un projet concret lui
lui webm est avec sa copine sa conjointe
et moi je cuisine et comment on peut
jumeler nos forces dans tout ça et on a
pensé à plein d'idées farfelues qu'on
peut voir sur le web à l'époque tu peux
vendre des recettes pour faire en sorte
de tout est gratuit mais mais au final
c'est je pense c'est vraiment mathilde
qui eut l'idée de dire que nous on
appelait il faisait de la production de
vidéos de skate board et on devrait
juste film et bob en train de nous
cuisiner de la bourse
puis mathieu sevin de nos blogs de
l'époque qui avait puis on est on est
heureux lit dans l'internet les trois
mois avant que youtube et si je me
trompe pas et c'est ça ou cantal un
courriel puis messenger puis c'est
agréable ça s'arrête parce que je mets
des filtres des photos avec des filtres
de fils à athus panier tissus et cette
ut longues vacances à illac à la
communauté au visage mais ceux qui
l'écoutent vaut peut-être sonné c'est à
l'époque avant que devenir une vedette
comme de tenchu qui quitte à se faire
connaître un peu mieux c'est impossible
de caen savine ça commence est
impossible de rester
moi je pense que j en passe quand
j'avais 27 ans quand j'ai commencé
projet et plus on marque un essai je
devais cave pour certains je me trouvais
d'être un peu cher mais restera en plus
une époque de ma vie je suis extrêmement
sur le parti si je resterai ou ce que le
port des rings fait que sa brosse son
mélange
un cocktail d'hadopi 2 good times puis
tout faire car est sa structure cadre
mais c'est correct je pense que tout ça
prend vite après à gérer avec ce mais en
même temps c'est bon parce je pense
sincèrement même temple de l'égout de
continuer à alpha est de plus en plus
connu et apprécié tarifs sa fin pour
d'autres raisons inconnues c'est
vraiment pas le but mais ça peut mettre
le cdh inventer des cas où des gens que
le confirmer j'ai bien géré je me
trouvais ça peut peut-être je me
trouvais mehmeti tout su et en dessous
du pont cette période de crise
cette arme est sur place des jo surtout
surtout ceux qui étaient là avant
c'est cette succursale en tabarnak 6 720
j'habite traque en colocation mais match
âme d'enfant stable en europe que je
parte ça s'appelle guy mais non six
comme par accident je te se poser
excusez-moi cm 1 or depuis lequel compte
suivre bombay
- il ya trois ans déjà châtel avec
j'avais une blonde et quand c'est
terminé je te les vives cher mais mais
mais bon tome d'enfance quel rôle je
m'appuie maudissait prat on perd mais
tout ce python puis déménage en a pas
puis 3 1 mais je cuisine bien probable
le chef qui cuisine fine nous accusons
souvent à la maison après ce qu'a
toujours cash le jeu cuisine bamako
l'accusé extrêmement habits indienne en
plus donc accuser plein de curry de
plats végétariens justement qui sont a
fait son propre fromage alors à faire
accuser comme une machine fait qu'un
travail proche en profite
puis je l'espère mais qu'un palace pas
mal c'est pas mal moins le colloque lui
va s'occuper du bébé qui ils étaient six
et ben c'est bien sa force se fait
dessus au quotidien mais toi tu fais tu
as tu des recettes goto que tu répètes
tout le temps au tc tout le temps de
faire de quoi qui pour que jamais fait
mais qui comme un peu et hors de la zone
ouais c'est cool être le web si je me
souhaite une bonne banque
on devrait quand même pas loin de 1000
recettes sur le site web
pab le chef points communs même étude la
façon de le web est fait par cette
histoire huit défaut c'est le fun
facettes qui existe déjà un sauvage lis
les commentaires de tout le monde qui
m'écrit qui me parle de des recettes qui
ont essayé qui ont fait des demis des
quais comme dit qu'il ya eu de la
musique universelle
j'essaie de la fed en semaine qui vient
question le devoir ce que tu vraiment
bien ce que ça leur réussit une voiture
une embauche à la clé mais tifo quoi on
n'a pas une grosse écumant les trois un
fait que l'art est satisfaits -1 cuisine
je fais la grossesse je mesure tout
j'essaie d'écrire sur un coin de table
au fur et mesure que ce que je fais bien
précieux je l'écris ans google docs ce
que j'en voyais à mathilde qui fait la
mise en ligne mais mais ça se peut des
fois je me trompe c'est surtout quand je
fais de la pâtisserie plus je me rends
compte a maintenant un demi poste a
passé un jeune a ajouté qu'en m ou
encore d'atteinte de plus puis un jour
m'a rappelé non c'est jamais bon sais tu
prends tu es les photos aussi de ta
bouffe ou est ce quelqu'un d'autre ce
que tu as oui puis j'ai pris de très
mauvaises photos pendant très longtemps
et je vais faire
j'avais fait ma groupe ige pris le cours
de photo de alex haley prenez ça m'a
intéressé
j'étais intéressé à photo j'ai juste un
très mauvais oeil mais ça m'a quand même
donné des idées simples 2 comment voir
là la bouffe qui de juste me trouver un
support chinook la loi est toujours
bonne à mémoire qui puisse me développer
un espèce de rails de travail qui
étaient très dures pour moi quelqu'un
j'ai arrêté de faire de la restauration
parce que toute ma vie j'ai tout croche
mais j'avais quand deux mini fallait que
je choisisse pas fléchir le plus dur est
passé brest-quimper crise grippe de sa
personne des fois je ne veux plus te
crache la fois les choix flèche bas sa
main quand je tombe très bien autonome
rail comme ceux c'était infernal
absolument tout cas pas tu devais te
lever pour que tard site de justement
une curie soient prêtes à 10 heures le
matin par celle de la lumière est
meilleure le exactement ok je vais aller
couper de live faire chauffer sur à
montfort le temps j'ai juste envie de
prendre un café puis mangé une toast
tout semble plus de fun que travailler
ses casquettes vu toutes les dates 4 vu
des reprises de docteur fils s'était
déjà vu mais j'ai je me structurer tiges
et j'ai pris du recul vers gaza le jeu
vous fait vraiment un orage comme si je
travaillais puis du terrain pour
répondre à mes courriels du temps pour
répondre au monde qui m'écrivent mais au
moins je le fais tout une shot ces hauts
lieux au lieu d'en faire un petit peu le
matin tout enfant un premier temps le
soin de temps car son instit téléphone -
entre six et neuf je ne touche pas mon
téléphone j'écoute un film je lis un
livre si ça sonne c'est ma mère ou la
mère de mon fils fait que je réponds pas
[Rires]
si ce monsieur là mon fils à ce moment
ça me fait chier tu réponds jamais aux
tab à 4 par 8e pour la question si cet
enfant quand on entend tout petit a pu
vraiment du lot vraiment le temps à
temps pour dépanner métier parce que le
mode de vie justin fernando s'est une
fois de temps en temps des matons
chaussures une fois par année il voit
quelqu'un besoin d'un garde manger
vendredi soir je vais aller donner un
coup de main je veux j'arrive à 5h par
minuit on paye même portée ont permis
une bouteille de vin jaune est super
konami puis on va régler ça demain mais
c'est le fun en fait c'est presque
participe à quelque chose était d'un
équipe il ya comme la course contre la
montre en place pas vrai assure loos
puis si tout va bien par leur âge c'est
vraiment le fun ici les sacs rage c'est
du saccage de joie c'est vraiment cool
c'est comme un genre de balai pour
vraiment parce que tu es vraiment 5 5
personnes dans un endroit gastrin et
personne n'arrive à s'accrocher 10 et
ses rangs du christ un coup de coude à
quelqu'un par erreur tout le monde su ce
qui allait le monde bouge bien
d'ailleurs ces gars 104 clinique bouge
mâle donne quand un nouveau cuisine en
cuisine c'est là que ça accroche le sou
oui oui mais tu vas le voir ainsi est
bon si ce n'est dans le coin bistrot
chemin mais si la demi-lieue piétonne
sur lui même mais pour qu'on garde
séraphin crise mais aussi travaillé un
an cage aux sports d'accuser croire
depuis qu'ils se devaient de salles en
école de voir ouais vraiment parce que
premièrement tout ce qui est normes de
salubrité si capte pas de pas de
meilleure place que cela aurait pu
manger mes informateurs littéralement
l'attenté en exception exacte tout à
fait paraître tout est pesé parfaitement
tout et je le rappelle a amené les
mardis des wings a et qui sont peu
chères le match sortait les wings puisse
traiter les wings la même façon que je
traite les wings l'egypte le mangera est
venu me voir il fait et les wings le
mardi c'est du caviar les faut que tu
leur donnes la monf et oui c'est
vraiment cessé c'est effectivement quand
quand tu dis quand tout va bien c'est
hot mais qu'un cancer en une espèce de
tension un peu merdique puis un petit
peu de de power trip de certains
cuisiniers parce que moi j'étais jeune
je plonge slash en arrière d'un four de
wing justement pis pilotes comme un
cuisinier qui leur qu'à 35 ans j'avais
seize puisqu'elle est lui lui c'est le
king ça c'est de la merde pour les
jeunes de 16 ans proche ouais mais
j'étais chanceux comme tous mes gars
manceau giorgio pire garde le je l'avais
dès demain un petit du monde des tiges
ou connaissances et que puis même si
c'est complètement car ce qu'ils
demandent c'est bah oui ça il faut
exactement cet exemple vont passer la
moppe c'est comme ok tu penses à mob de
ce côté là quand la mode est propre et
sale tu tournes la mode de l'autre côté
tu passes du côté de ça je faisais non
vos surfaces comme un super gars à ses
restos les ondes et gerard piqué qu'il
ya beaucoup de monde qui casse le cul
d'un safari 4 soit dans le haut de gamme
c'est cool parce qu'un chef en personne
te parle 6 une serveuse ou un serveur
aux carmes critique un plat au garde
manger le chef samedi
le chef populiste au besiktas ans
justement le chef avec phi phi chef je
pense d'abord du monde m'ont trouvé
sympathique battre mais il doit un autre
monde qu'ils ont fait mais aussi si un
client qui trouve que la viande avait
pas bien cuite qui traînent dans
l'assiette puis le la série dallas vient
de voir comme chef dit ouais le client
pas content qu'il se passe quoi et que
client qu'attend aussi tu attends je
sais c'est ma fierté taux d'igf 1 24e je
me suis fait virer deux steaks hachés
c'est un bien cuit celle là mais depuis
le ive les gens médias monsieur
immédiate elle méritait ce jour des
accords ce week-end pour pour ce qui est
qui qui ont pas vraiment jamais fait
cuisine moi j'ai trouvé que tu me direz
que ce temps passe je trouvais que le
plongeur était extrêmement représentatif
absolue ce qui se passe avait décrit ses
il décrit jusqu'à l'odeur y quand on
peut cuisiner longtemps une cuisine
seront ya une odeur particulière dans
plonge d'accuser détergents l' espèce de
mélange les arrange de détergents et de
grottes
cc c'est quelque chose pourrait même
voir sa fille il vraiment caricom du
monde pourrait même être un bon mélange
de fiction et de vérité ce livre parce
que
j'en ai parlé beaucoup avec lui comme la
question qu'on pose de plus c est ce que
b bat existants lisez le livre pauvre
elle aussi a absolument absolument et et
bebye existe de l'est vivent deux fils
quelques brèves tb bas de gamme existe à
sa faillite a pas longtemps
puis c'est un joyeux lurons mais bastien
christy de bangle
à faire mais j'ai comme un peu pris sa
place au mistook à lui l'ont sacré
d'artistes comme un succès pas
absolument puis mais de la façon dont
josé gager lu le livre je la façon qu'il
décrit la la cuisine ce que je plaçais
mes trucs c'est ce c'est toute la vérité
le l'expression utilisée souvent des
critiques littéraires participants c'est
quand elle se livre le pardon c'est un
bateau dans le cuba ou le barca
d'aptitude [ __ ] et était gros ça brasse
un peu plus que la foule qui venait on
savait jamais quel genre dans la foule
qu'on l'ait d'abord à voir mais on
savait café de la souris le wac dames
d'abord heads ou pigeons n'était pas
rien on est bien sorti j'ai une amie qui
nie ses amis elle est écoutée dans les
restos par comme quatre appuis puis mon
ami a dit un joke
mais après les pas de quotas qui a
décidé d'arrêter métier ça dépend des
goûts et ses programmes attractifs une
exagération métier comme dans le sens de
dire qu'elle est celle de vie pas pour
tout le monde c'est absolument vivre
avec mes cachets haut de gamme dans des
restos beaucoup plus haut de gamme ont
travaillé beaucoup trop pour fêter ça
cette semaine n'avait pas serait pas
temps de récupérer je devrais y est tu
dormais la vrine sonnerie pis certains
vit pas mal
même éthique enjeux tard vous mr j'étais
arrivé comme une époque de ma vie où
j'avais peut-être plus aiguë des cracher
dessus goodkind 70e semaine j'avais dit
qu'on a un peu plus relax pis je me suis
vite rendu compte que c'était le
restaurant qui offensent elle resterait
que de la mauvaise réputation était
notamment puis je pense pas que personne
n'était plus tard et c'était juste un
collectivement ce moment dans l'univers
ces gens de 12 personnages le sont
alignés et on fait la faillite par un
bon trois ans
mais c'est le moment que j'ai pas de
règle cg non mais c'est tout derrière -
c'était pas clair de ma vie même est des
fois j'ai un peu des fois j'en parle pas
foule parce que j'ai l'impression que je
devrais être moralisateur puis dire au
monde si comme vous devriez pas failli
ce petit même si je ne dis pas que je
leur ferai mais j'ai eu pendant le temps
que je les fais j'ai eu beaucoup de fun
alpha gerry adams a comme prêcher les
corps ce site a dit fais le toi tu es un
petit gain un petit gars de 10 ans il va
être entendu ce même s'ils s'y fait de
la restauration du vote il encourager
l'installation en autant qu'ils aillent
à l'école puis qui a c'est le choc parce
ça me dérange pas je danse je
l'encouragé n'est pas le coût qui est
goût d'essayer qui qui qui qui sert à
l'avancement de la ville un jour
investie puis ça me fait plaisir de
l'encourager la belle récompense que ce
n'est pas dit il faut que tu es enfant
tu l'as fait des erreurs je ne te faire
manger une famille de même le jeudi oui
j'avais un respect de ma mère que je
savais comme les c'est peut-être sortie
d'un pub tard que mes amis zafarana msp
et mai
avec eux avec 6 km puis jetée comme le
plus jeune la gang des sketches avec
financer ce qui le faisait du mauvais
coup un vin qui faisait tout avec ou
sans voler puis moi j'aimais ça m'a mené
avec les gunners et les mauvais coups
mais cave dalton fallait mauvais coup à
jouer à l'ailé bon ici après des années
plus tard accepté que je m'approprie y
est monnaie courante
[Musique]
parler comme c'était le cas jusqu'à peu
près ça va mais ce pas longtemps puis
les prix vers le bas
je vous salue marie à ces cadenas d'un
back with hic est qu'il va mettre
complètement heil oui les classes avec
elton john ami je le nomme réponds que
je la vis pour h qui est allé à messe de
minuit sol acide
gfr gfr de l'acide ya une fois dans ma
vie la vraie assise debout comme qui
existaient début des années 90 il ya
passé la finale 5 minuscule le très gros
coup en tête des feuilles
14h02 bon d'accord c'est oui je vais pas
perdre mais si des pires puis fait que
je m'imagine pas à la messe de minuit
cela se veut
c'était cool contexte et avec cet été où
tu faisais quoi la droite avec des cha
cha à pointe aux trembles pi est
absolument vrai mais lorsque tout
adolescent blanc oui oui le temps passe
normalement mais je te dirais la page et
de tout ce câble est là elle c'est
vraiment l'fun les premiers 3,88 rites
sont nécessairement n'est peut-être plus
de ferrari et puis un drop le destin
londres est à moi j'ai vraiment j'ai
près mais ce
j'avais 16 ans et demi comme annoncé que
sa blonde enceinte quand ça compte pas
le temps de tout reid lui a pris mais
ces gens là enfin je me suis détaché de
la bière au départ puis on a rentré dit
attends que sanaa en barque plantes
grasses tifo kung fu qu'on s'achète
d'arbres ou le thé avec s'embarque tout
sauf un ont co des pick up dans le frigo
a bien quelque chose arrive que les deux
hommes mais moi j'étais un cri s
entassent des mauvaises affaires
je trouvais public cible pour les
politiques viennent aux écoles
secondaires pour te dire oui le s'il est
possible dans mon école et j'avais 14
ans pour me dire de parfum de la drogue
qui donne des exemples la drogue du
monde ils prennent du buffle slavija
devient comme une bande dessinée la
façon dont elle explique aussi c'est
tout un dimanche je voyais
je sais pas pourquoi je voyais comme un
baume qui fâchent pays près de la cible
et brad la cochlée fini qui choque les
rails vu un pilote ya aussi un printemps
premier job d'un restaurant à petit que
lui fait la peau de vendredi soir et un
bungalow une femme trois enfants puis
pas ménagé ses efforts il ya quelqu'un
qui me manquent pas pour expliquer ce
que tu parlais que tu faisais du ski
tantôt puis juste avant qu'on compare tu
parles tu avais une comparaison le skate
le live skydrive de la restauration
absolument ces deux lifestyle que
citadel vraiment lifestyle c'est
accepter damvix aspect-là repos mais
c'est vrai mais je me souviens quand bob
le chef va quand même commencer à
décoller je travaille encore misto en
pis puis j'ai travaillé je suppose
chance justement le pôle le propriétaire
imac m'accommoder shia trois jours
semaine les lundi mardi mercredi comme
si je parlais reste la semaine pour
aller faire des démos de cuisine fin des
festivals des trucs dedans avec bob le
chef puis je me suis marché comme sa
traque des trains vraiment à ces clichés
de ce que j'osais mais je vous le jure
le qui séparait heureusement au plateau
mont royal et du post-it du cheval je
peux marcher sa retraite que je marchais
là tout les jours avant d'aller
travailler
puis je marchais pour aller travailler
ou je dois travailler puis
je me principal adjoint j'ai tout un
tapis pauvre il j'ai tout temps tout le
temps était au boulot à pied ça
rafraîchit ce fait du bien parce que tu
possèdes une voiture maintenant oui je
fais juste trois ans ah ouais ouais
toyota corolla parfait j'aime les champs
c'est juste mon premier changé mis
tellement l'argent dans le vide que le
must est un char fiable mais oui je me
suis dit sur cette traque de train est
vraiment accepter le fait que j'avais 35
36 ans puis j'avais pas beaucoup
d'argent dans mon compte de banque
fixed a probablement la réalité comme
pas quelque chose qui te pour m'arriver
dans la vie que je travaille jusqu'à ma
mort puis vraiment d'être à la sof que
je vis je vienne est une belle vie des
afghans
c'est la part du mans n'ont pas la
chance de faire et puis moi j'ai choisi
sur pie jeu l'accès pleinement
puis je pense quand tu t'investis comme
le ski erreurs mais je trouve ces
cerveaux olympiques mais je suis de la
vieille école qui trouve encore c'est un
espèce de style de vie même si je quitte
plus quand je me considère comme un peu
comme un espèce de scanner dans
l'armoire que toute ma vie je passais à
côté d'un cette démarche ou d'une rampe
d'escalier et je veux imaginer un truc
c'est senna large du mexique là la
semaine possible je roule en charge et
là c'est d'avoir mis en jambes si je
serai capable fayçal aux pilotes sont
inscrits en comptes en date un bon kid
il traîne des skates pas être n'importe
où je me suis dit waouh match je me
remets admettait le ratio ces deux biens
et park et flip
[Rires]
les deux fois plus de style de vie du
caylar pétanque et le court compagnie
faille de la vidéographie ou de la
photographier un cac pendant tout et qui
accepte le risque tâche est pas d'airé
picchu vieille cuisine c'est issard
samassa absolument
il ya beaucoup de monde dès fois tv puis
ils pensent des riches c'est ce que
laisse deux mètres le puits si ça fait
vraiment mais j'ai commencé cette année
à mettre de l'argent de côté ma retraite
je t'oublie même je trouve quand même
chercher 43 ans pouvoir cammas alpha
s'est donné au moins j'ai pu détenant
vip tourné par longtemps loin de maths à
mettre de l'argent de côté pour mes
vieux jaune je te pose de cuisine chez
raguet je bois mais c'est vraiment
effectivement une nouvelle fois une
belle façon de voir ce pardon de se dire
d'arriver en paix avec qui est ce que
ton mode de vie peu éventuels que ton
mode de vie peut éventuellement terminer
juste dit si tu crois c'est que ses
collègues
ouais ce serait correct mais j'aime et
ont justement été admis siens de dire ok
ça se peut que j'avais besoin de faire
des ging longtemps encore à ce que j'ai
écoute moi je comprends pleinement le
trip de travailler pour ta retraite je
comprends pleinement seul parce que
peut-être qu'un jour oui je vais arrêter
de travailler finalement puis ça serait
cool de pouvoir elle fait ok mais
souvent les gens comme tu disais les
musées ou les cuisiniers ou l'esquirol
et les peintres les artistes y ont
quelque chose que benzema n'en ont pas
la chance de vivre leur vie privée de
leurs passions bien
ce ceux des fois par là longtemps gelé
peut-être trop facile moi je dise que ma
patience des cuisines je suis pas en
parler mes managers paris legault autant
que je parle beaucoup dans les podcasts
ou dans les situations où je dois pas
quand je venais parti je suis vraiment
pas l'avis du parti shass très renfermé
je suis pas un pro m
sauf si tu me donnes un couteau planche
à découper leur exemple j'ai discret à
piles paribas lâche pas pour autant que
ça arrive c'est du parti ou est-ce que
ça est bof une une démo je fais un peu
de cas le ring comme ceux gdd des
particuliers tard hier pour moi je
n'entends pas que je ferai à ce temps en
plus jusqu'à mes chances j'en faisais
comme rim d'hommes mais le muscat maire
martine banque de clients si j'ai pas
goût d'en faire plus mais même si c'est
quoi on mange et un pigiste navy des
fois décembre janvier c'est des mois un
peu plus raf fait que dans le temps des
fêtes une coupe de paris de noël puis
j'aime c'est justement ça je tombe mal
j'ai eu un peu un petit crash faucheuse
m'a mise en place
c'est le fun aussi jazz et clermont est
juste un gars très très clairement même
si beaucoup jaser de cuisine puis ça me
fait tout imploser le tableau de ce
souvent owens et des pages et une
assistante qui ma coloc président
huawei puis
si j'ai besoin d'un coup de main
suivante donne un coup de main mais en
attend un groupe jusqu'à 15 personnes je
les robes de gérer ce camp mais qu'elle
commet et mettons que moi je veux faire
en partie virtuelle 15 personnes le
circuit ce que je décris temps mais toi
je pourrais très confortable le jeune
homme en béton pour quelqu'un qui sait
je vis tout mais mon père pour pour la
fin de vraiment il y avait le restaurant
la vie à tort à québec
eh bien c'est la diététique l'aviatic
cardon qui est aussi dans fait ses dents
gare du palais avec y avait le chef de
ce jeu j'ai oublié son nom
le chef de la via tic puis offrait ce
genre d'affaires l'autre mon père pour
la femme de 50 ans ma mère avait il
avait fait venir chez nous le pire
n'était comme si à tout type y avait en
effet sitruk cuisine en cuisine de ma
mère puis comme le diester qui montre à
mamers et recettes puis qu'est ce qu'ils
faisaient là c'était malade mental qui
mangeaient l'aviatic pour moi je fais la
musique dans vie puis j'en ai joué j'ai
joué dans un crissement des restos fac
tu manges le l'aviatic men c'est une des
meilleures places je suis je sais faire
blogue
on cherche quand je vais pas m'en charge
c'est exactement ces housses de la gare
du palais et s'est enfermé puis on va à
nouveau resto à sainte foy genre je
pense que oui à la fin mai mais ouais
parlant de ses droits parce que à part
entière tout j'ai joui même une place je
n'aimerais pas le mettre une place à
québec
genre c'est assez une fois petit c'est
vraiment reconnu sa grosse réputation
sérieuse haut le puits jouer leur jeu la
musique lugeur en 2014
si ces gens on se promène à travers les
tables acoustique avec la guitare chant
guitoune au monde le coller sur le monde
puis le boss labo tilt et l'ambiance du
plongeur le que ça bourdonne dans le
monde sait qu'ils apprennent que c'est
qu'il soit tendu le maine je l' ai
tellement vu lol cette ambiance le beau
style je me suis amené on chantait bonne
foi et à peu près
douze fois par soir une fois qu'elle
tablait venir faire la fête le tarif le
plus fou tu fasses les bonnes fêtes les
plus enthousiastes et alfie douze fois
par soir
le monsieur manuel avait fait un bonne
fête fils le proprio le boss et elle n
avait vu lui même est venu nous voir là
là là c'est plus que ça à la plus de
plus en plus intense que ça pète une
coche à cause qu'on n'avait pas chanté
bonne foi assez intensément son goût
puis c'est drôle parce que je m'ennuie
si je participe québec avait chanté
bonne fight comme blanc comme si bonne
version que le combat va quand même pas
s'arrêter avec sa fille c'est qu'en mai
mais c'est drôle parce qu'en venant ici
je pense qu'avec que j'avais un ami
gaulle une passagère qui a travaillé le
dans ce resto las palmas zigolos ligne
pas changer puis j'arrive à bien par les
temps c'est beaucoup c'est à sassari
c'est ce déclin c'est beaucoup de restos
il ya beaucoup de bien mais ne
souhaitais pas le nom mais qui donc est
oui puis non dada et que mon cas je
voulais donner chef haut de gamme chez
traits d'un resto qui s'appelait
méditerranée ou parce que je connaissais
la réputation du restaurant sans les
restaurants les plus tough d'alfred soir
tof pour travailler le pied bot tant
mieux si l'on souhaitait aller oui j'ai
eu à prendre des meilleurs puis je
rentre elop stains équipe il y avait
jean 7 go trois faits puis warman
attache ta tuque se sait quelque chose
les des jeux 10 mai mais ce que j'aime
la cuisine c'est le monde extérieur n
existe qu importe pour l'église et parce
qu'on passe beaucoup de temps en
cuisinant vidéo mais comme l'espèce de
débats sur le sexe et les femmes son
pays il a même briques lego refusé
les serveuses en cuisine ouais mais même
que dans un restaurant comme tel en
restauration les femmes sont souvent
plus payés que les gueules absolument
dans le coût du service vous avez les
cuisiniers mais mais mais mais tu ici il
ya vraiment ses coûts la cuisine poste
s'il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas on
regarde au delà des races les sexes
c'est comme c'est juste une femme il
accumule tout le monde sait quelque
chose j'ai bien aimé mais cachelou
méditerranée aussi se mouche voulait le
parce que statoil travailler puis puis
avait deux chefs en cuisine puis c'est
capoté parce que j'ai appliqué j y avait
une annonce dans précis chercher chemin
du monde des journaux ce sévère
quel âge qui est avec 22 zac est prévu
un début de début 2000 à leur appel
puis entre que j'arrive puis j'ai
entrevu pour aller le permet pas il n'y
a pas de web rien dit allez porter ton
vivant personne puis j'avais juste une
chemise à cette époque là est à blanche
qui tabarnak arrive une tâche ne suffira
pas l'argent jimmy du liquid paper sur
ma chemise noc et puis j'avais jusqu'à
pâques
je mets ces chemises d'un pantalon
j'assume ma ceinture un stade où j'ai
l'air un peu plus leurs pis fait que
j'assume et la ceinture stade le liquid
paper sa chemise puis je te jure les
deux les deux chefs et ont supporté les
deux affaires pendant la revue puis je
pense ses gardes il livrera job comme
les tâches et les cacher
y en a besoin fini si c'était
extrêmement rigoureux très vraiment tort
j'en ai fait de l'examen
ok
tellement que cette offre mais quand je
suis sorti de ce cadre du lunel
j'étais vraiment mercuzot et puis j'ai
vu des cuisines et qu'on passait par là
puis ses pieds puis je ne dis pas que
tout le monde toutes les restaurants de
la planète
ça devrait être comme ça mais il faut
qu'une certaine rigueur qu'ils ont et
écoute je comprends que peut-être
quelqu'un qui plus sensibles moi ça
devenait cuisinier et que c'est moche
comparer un art mais autant que ben
moubarak savourer tout ou rien mais mais
se sont heurtés patrick c'est quelque
chose de très impoli à faire c'est
d'aller en quelques pas puis vouloir
changer le système qui est implanté un
site souvent dans un resto et puis il ya
ça veut pas dire que tu sois tu as écrit
apriste une cuisine il ya plein de place
que ses plus chauds puis après le job
qui sont vraiment intéressantes la
cuisine super travail et s'est
brusquement retiré au début c'est que tu
peux voyager jeudi quelque chose qu'on
va quand même partout sa planète c'est
qu'on bouffe fait que tout d'avoir un
job
ok dit si tu étais un passionné de
cuisine l'est pas décourager par des
citoyens d'autres fins écrit après moi
il va envoyer chaussure à son pied mais
ce que je recommande aux gens par
facebook et par une certaine rigueur
fierté de turpitudes et ballet aux
ordres on sait c'est trop top ça devrait
pas dedans même les métiers non ça
devrait de même chez eux explique
formera crise de bouc la ville perd son
top et les hameaux été pillés caous
exemple le chef le puits ce qui se dit
dans services comme un match dans quinze
jours à paris la cuisine à tout
aujourd'hui
mais ce qui se dit çà glace de sa glace
depuis afin de la game on s'en sort pas
mal quand même
et puis c'est ce qui arrive et on la
fuit avec josé tantôt à z ségolin a
pendant de bosses de restauration bien
ce que cela reste tout ce qu'il aurait
fréquenté une serveuse
oui oui
c'est d'y croiser en dehors mais ton
futur au party de noël du resto bâti jeu
se mettront un moment qu'ils étaient en
train de travailler ainsi que le
pichichi et fais toi dans le resto des
salades n'est que mathématique de
différents pays
[Rires]
fleury rapidement l'effet que les
serveuses ont travaillé au type n'est
justice le fait qu'il ya vraiment une
disproportion en mettant le salaire
qu'ils savaient se fait plus que je vais
poursuivre la question tu apprécies je
te lance la balle bob mais moi quand
justement j'étais à 15 aux sports ma
soeur travailler les mêmes chiffres que
moi on avait réussi à cette armée pour
les mêmes chefs pour faire du
covoiturage père léthel était sur le
plancher puis mettons charte est de
m'assurer tout d'école si vous allaitez
replonge c'était la voie ouest et
emploie plus le ti fallait qu'on allait
dès que je suis double chez nous me
frotter dans douche c'était dégueulasse
ce tableau watson c'est la tronche et
s'apprête à 2 chez kcm pauvres et aux
gens de chez nous
j'avais été j'avais fait 80 ans j'avais
80 pièces le rejeter a dit pièces de
leur cellule à ma soeur a certes est 2e
avec 250 300 pièces qui était encore à
elle aurait pu sortir dans un club
oui ça tombait encore tout pimpant et un
maquillage nude pie xi et quoi ça ne
sera pas là le sessad n'a pas cessé
huchon puis là dedans fait prendre
position ça mais
mais pitié comme j'ai dit à tous mais
j'avais accepté le fait que bibi ingéré
plus j'étais très jeune charismatique
les prix de serveurs en fait la pièce
sur exemple ma carrière mais ceci étant
dit acquis aux dépens
le serveur du pourboire parce que dans
la gastronomie française
le serveur tout il arrive à la table ils
mélangent et le tartan il brûlait la
crème brûlée il faisait des crêpes
suzette il ya avec le chariot est
recommandé le fromage
il faisait tout le serveur une fille de
16 ans qui connaît que c'est tout le
monde a besoin de travailler qui l'a
placé à l as ta merde à tomber après
s'être un serveur qui vient de donner
menu un vent et l'eau servie par le base
ball dit le suit à rakita même ton assia
fait que non ça n'a pas de bon sens en
même temps j'ai beaucoup de mes amis que
son serveur mondiaux mais fuck beau
monde a faim mais c'est extrêmement mal
géré ça devrait beaucoup plus réglementé
il devrait avoir il devrait avoir un
partage de tout sous ils devraient pas
de salaire minimum des serveurs non plus
tout le monde devrait payer le même ce
titre et puis qui explique peut-être à
bollée les pourboires puis peut-être
juste avoir un prix fixe peut-être aussi
aider les dix faudrait qu'il ya certains
restèrent vont vouloir me fusiller déçu
mais peut-être un espèce d'algue pour
réglementer tout ça de façon je sais pas
une association peut-être quelque chose
c'est sûr que ça règlerait les problèmes
de main d'oeuvre une cuisine oui par
capita jeudi je pense que reste à rien
par 250 personnes à montréal un faux
sang elle appuie quelque chose si la
fidélité de la clientèle disparu au fil
des ans je vais à padern attend le joe
beef
express pis quelques autres restent aux
réactions des gros noms sont
probablement prochainement être victime
de cette joute le kaki qui on est
d'accord mais de temps en temps des
portes est de militer pour ce qu'on
croit même pas failli à répétition pipi
pourquoi s'attaquer aux jo bhi vraiment
le quelqu'un qui cassait de faire de
quoi avec la viande
ethiquement élevé qui sait de sa vie qui
encourage des fermiers locaux attaquent
tout le monde crache un mcdo à qui
puisse vraiment pour le suspect comme
double impression c'est vraiment pour
les symboles dans l'espace public se bat
c'est pourquoi ils ont choisi joe beef
c'est que il venait d'avoir un gros
article sur le joe beef qui valorise et
les entrepreneurs hop avec raison tout
le monde fait sa fortune avec ton
histoire de cépie puis délégué joseph
6,6 des entrepreneurs québécois qui se
lancent en business j'ai de quoi être
content
la culture vraiment plus haute que semer
mais c'était parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup d'expositions dans la
dernière semaine fait que lyon de style
mais c'est pas la façon faire excuser
moi les sh hésita qui enterrait six
heures on devrait tout réglementer ce
qui est je dis c'est évident que le
serveur partie - activement qui a déjà
participé dans l'ordre la restauration
je pense que certains restaurants qui
font une espèce d'équité salariale comme
le lien je pense que le joe beef
s'arrange que les cuisinistes ou très
bien rémunérés par rapport au savoir des
places comme si je ne sais pas en même
temps le juge spécule même certains
restaurants heureusement qui aura bolide
pour boire et puis tout le monde est
payé comme le même salaire mais je
trouve que peut-être fait comme plus en
france ou que ça dit vraiment
un métis est un métier dans nos français
de cuisines je pense qu'on s'en va c'est
au québec mais on a encore du travail je
des loges qui m'ont en même temps je
fais de la webtélé salut bonjour week
end je t'aime et liszt mais c'est
quelque chose qui m'intéresse que j'aime
chez toi ça on en parlait pitié des
fautes idiotes eu l'idée de faire un
resto pub différents tabarnak ses coups
que j'ai encore ce petit côté le club de
mon look emo 6 prouvé hier tps vos potes
bien plus des médias le monde oublie que
j'étais cuisinier je pense que je n'ai
lui personnellement entendu ce genre de
commentaire prouvez attaque humain je
pense que j'ai une idée mais c'est ça ma
ville c'est aux accents très peu
comparable oui oui deux peuvent être
placés
alors maman alors moment de ta vie aussi
je t'aime comme tu dis à 22 points
non j'aime pas d'énergie ailleurs matin
dit aux gars le soir c'est vrai tu fais
avec
avec gigante venu ici super 15 déduire
que tu fais de la course à pied - qui
compte encore bas toute l'année
j'écoute beaucoup mon camp un but - de
la main que j'ai mal comme cela
la semaine passée je rencontre à québec
puis je me suis mon pays un bel hôtel
fait que j'ai profité du jim et jamais
personne de jim d'hôtel en plus riches
tellement pas jean le cam se verront
jamais dans un si beau c'est que
jusqu'au jacques risque de perdre au
rivage est tout aussi mon masque tout le
kit le moins 20 kva et couric des skis
géants mourir d'asthme alors bref j'ai
couru sur un tapis roulant même damien
je pense qu enfin si le genou un peu
puis tué cette semaine je fais de la
marche à pied tu m'aimais habituellement
je sais les cours et 4g c'est lui
courait après 40 kilomètres par semaine
cambrai quelconque façon que ce soit en
trois quatre ou cinq sorties puis des
semaines je perds deux fois comme ceux
des plus c'est bon t'as fait des
marathons et le train je veux tel est lé
marathon d'ottawa j'ai couru les 42
kilomètres au complet ce test est
vraiment cool
jean frey qui
dix ans et demi de plus que moi puis le
l'inattendu monde la famille puis mon
frère avait déjà couru cinq six
marathons
puis il ya une coupe d'art et de cinéma
dit qu il me reste moins de marathon
cours et que j'en ai couru puis ça
serait le fun qu'on a couru ensemble
fait pendant longtemps au stade rennais
pour courir ce test marathon le puis on
a fait 29 km côte à côte
vraiment puis elle m'a dit je courais un
peu plus vite que lui puis j'ai commencé
à partir j'avais bu pauvre j'ai chanté
que j'avais l'énergie paru en mai
dernier 10 km un peu plus dans le tapis
puis pour lui puis de gamme sap et je te
vaut pour moi plus que ma tristesse j'ai
regardé au displayport
j'ai fini gamme seat ou huit minutes
étrangers fait 4-4 puis lui 4 à 11 ans
n'a pas la même le sait je n'ai pas gelé
pour échapper aux taxes dernier cf j'ai
couru un marathon de québec ce fait deux
ans que je cours depuis cette année j'ai
vraiment eu du béton l'année d'avant
c'était ça a été tu offres disponibles
en deux minutes quand j'arrivais à 33 kg
maintenant le mail à cette année là j'ai
vraiment va peut-être en tout cas
tchèque j'aimerais sans fin cette année
je peux choisir quelque 40 kg par
semaine
et prépare deux mois d'avancé
correctionne sortie d'à peu près 28 29
km piste et carrick excitante car elle
serait capable par le dernier 13 km qui
musicaux quand même rapidement quand
jusqu'au quotidiennement le jeu qu à peu
près cinq minutes du kilomètre pose du
cuivre sur papier
ben quand je crois en attente était
distant gobain énorme massif ya beaucoup
de monde qui accèdent à commencer la
course à pied qui sont pas capables en
cas de carence à courir parce que l'on
voudrait que quand tu l'a jamais fait
tu cours à bloc mélissa 180 d'un pas
tout et pour tout le monde sait ce qu'un
média moi je parle à plein de monde
des fois je ris y ait des gens avec des
dyades pitot que j'aurais pu au fait
c'est parce que pour certains gens
certes andy yates à sauver leur vie
typique du monde pour un maton à la
diète quête au bon moi je peux
complètement pas comprendre comment
juste manger de la viande des protéines
c'est bon pour tout le monde et qu'il ya
vraiment du monde que ça le semble-t-il
changé leur mini foot respecte ce n'est
pas pour moi moi je plusse méditerranée
et dans mon style de vie mais cette idée
est apparemment ben c'est juste du fils
qui est frais mais depuis de le
rapatrier au québec un peu fait que ces
temps-ci d'hambourg beaucoup de légumes
racines chez nous les livrer plus de
grock l'été et il était beaucoup de
salades des protéines plus de décoder
l'entier des trucs de manger un bon
steak c'est ainsi d'avis que tu le fais
toujours ce n'est pas ce qu'on leur j'ai
jamais rencontrée mais j'ai son livre
chinois huawei et puis il va revenir
bientôt d'ailleurs au cepii c'est lui
vraiment justement l'approchent antilles
est plus qu un petit match de manger des
aliments non transformés cuisiner mais
bon de l'autre c'est vraiment le truc
super simple qui était pas besoin de
savoir tout les nutriments toutes les
affaires qui toutes les affaires de
super et l'immeuble des cibles de ce doc
sont apparus aussi compétente qui le
voudront y va de la pause facebook je
t'aime petit comme gaz
je sois là j'espère un petit rappel que
j'ai à ce jour la science ne pas encore
trouvé de diète mirror pour lui parler
pour la perte de poids pour la perte de
poids
yapo des diètes kiki vo chi chi chi se
démontrer que sur le long terme si vous
fonctionnez la plupart dédié
on va remarquer les gens après quelques
années reprennent leur plus les livres
quand perdu pis ils disent donc genre on
va arrêter il dit c'est vraiment mal
l'exercice s'est jamais tarie y'a pas
déjà fait un mois des bois séché clé a
toutefois perdu les écoles messieurs
s'est affalé c'est comme ça je fais
jamais le moi j'aime ça c'est quand tu
le fais quantifie de la part de même tu
peux te rendre compte à quel point un
effet immédiat
tu peux en avoir dans n'importe qu'elle
dit à tim et en même temps que moi
demain matin je tombe pied tall sûr que
kétou vegan ça a été impossible mais
donc je tombe qui est au c sur que si
j'arrête de manger des pâtes pendant
deux semaines j'ai perdu pour lui c'est
sûr même chose avec n'importe quel team
et mettons le mois sens bien mais c'est
sûr que si j'arrête de boire de la bière
fans en un mot apparaît automatiquement
sur un principe tout l'effet que c'est
juste de dire comme justement à dire
cette agence est tellement restrictif
ces cui est moins restrictif cei - même
si mes donc même si je manger de la
viande de je me vois pas cuisiner sain
légumes ou sans fruits mais même quand
je fais des démos de cues homogène tout
temps en temps faire une petite recette
de droit serait pour montrer aux gens
justement tchèque excuses end et
blandine même si nous autres qui le fait
le chèque la carte sexy que je mets dans
ces faits mais 10 de la fin c'est moi je
mets cette barre ce qu'imaginent le
produit très oui mais la même quantité
de ce que mogi admettent mais deux
versions plus personne n'en sait déjà
c'est là que je trouve très importante
je t'aime à se réapproprier nos chaudron
c'est au québec que l'on ait la place la
moins américaine des pipiers par un
bouche à lundi paris du mexique mais
j'arrive de pipe c'est fou comment
azotés ont comme tout les produits de
marde des états unis sont dopés au
mexique
puis on est chanceux au québec on se
trouve devant et toute cette agriculture
d'avoir toutes ces produits locaux mais
où il est quand même un peu au québec la
dent région de saguenay sont les mères
via les malfrats malesza contenant les
meilleurs fruits de mer que la planète à
offrir josé partout on a une spécialité
au québec qui je trouve ça important
qu'on profite de ce clip c'est pas
compliqué le québécois moyen même si on
parlait que je faisais là dit régis brun
- mangez frais au québec c'est un c'est
encore des remplace que c'est moins cher
qu'à manger de la bouffe transformée
jeudi un brocoli chou-fleur une poche de
patates d'oignons du lait du beurre la
farine tout coupe fine semaine complète
de repos
pis ses pochoirs pauvres et le bon je
crie pas qu'on peut nourrir une femme et
les 4 70 ans
mais ce fait sa propre bouffe passé puis
c'est la meilleure façon justement de
trouver un espèce d'équilibré dans tout
seul homme pour seltz pramac va manger
mieux parce que moi je dit résolument
deuxièmement tout va encore étonné que
ton économie locale toi rené paquet
écologique - grand parce que i les
aliments parcourent une distance à win
win win tout à fait ça pour ça il ya
beaucoup de tirs on a beaucoup beaucoup
de produits qui se font ici moi je pense
au tofu devant il fait en bosses mais il
y en aura c'est parce qu'il ya pas une
grosse pénurie
on dit qu'à cause des looney
prochainement un enchaînement d'affaires
le loup ni avec son tapis magique qui
est conne qui a été remis à
en fait il est arrivé qu'un le tofu
général tao de ricardo puis de
jean-philippe ont comme explosion mais
en même temps ça n'a amené que tu
trouves est puni le porte bagages en
charge ce fut par exemple absolument
tout arrêté par la semaine le mois
bg je fais je plus d'un cheveu attention
[Rires]
qu'on disait sexistes cesser les bonnes
habitudes c'est pas une affaire de 1
mois ci à mossoul si je sais que ce
puits justin lin avec tout ce qui ce
passe dans le monde je trouve que en
catégorie trop ce qu'on mange
puis ça fait des débats complètement
inutiles jeudi et a chois radio etc j'en
ai eu comme un mouvement anti viggen
puis après ce lévy guinée avait le
carnivore puis après ça vieillit juste
allemands 2
j'ai l'impression que on y est on
devrait évoluer au delà de ce qu'on soit
8 mai mais il faut arrêter de se mettre
dans déclarant fermé jean jacques cambra
peau moi j'étais à l'école secondaire
les fresh risques et les alternatifs il
y avait toutes ses enfants puis je
trouvais ça tellement compliqué pour les
jeux à ce titre cool - à l'âge adulte
je n'ai pas dit l'ex puis je le dis
encore pays j'ai l'impression puis bin
oui des fois je bouffe un plat qui à
base de légumes mais je t'oublie jeudi
que selon lui absolument végétarien dont
je mange mon super sais je sais que je
bouffe
puis quand je bouffe du barbecue c'est
pas pied de nez politique mais je
respecte une pige à près de tout le
monde
j'apprends au temps du gauquier carnival
qui refuse de manger une asperge dans
son année que j'appréhendais quelqu'un
qui refuse de manger un steak c'est
juste que moi j'aime absorber tout ce
qui me gêne que le monde découvre le
plus d'affaires pour se trouve c'est
pisser entend le c'est carrément je
respecte le monde qui font un homme
attend que son viguen pour l'éthique
animale je respecte absolument chocobo
même j'aimerais ça la volonté mot même
de le faire mais j'aime trop le fromage
à québec je le fais pas mais en même
temps je sais le profile chier le monde
avec ce qui je pense est le que si au
lieu d'1 semaine d'un clin pige chez des
rats chicago boys humeur si on
s'approche et me replonge en zep et puis
ses pions le fait même dans mon monde
entier pas de casse bob le chef la boue
j'ai reçue lui ni avec la gagne la
brosserie rap et rock 100 des vikings
littéralement accusé et or on a fait un
espèce de planches grue il mixe grille
du barbecue où il y avait d'un côté de
la frontière et de ligue 1 donc côté de
la viande n'ont été capables de se
rejoindre la frontière dans une diction
et une jante sont toutes sortes et au
lieu de jeu se fermer fait que c'est ça
je faisais je fais des plans de l'entier
des fois je mets du fort de vaux déjà
possédé lentilles bourguignon
puisqu'un pleuvait geste je ne sais pas
si est bon plat par exemple denise
bombardier messe à canet fc bâle a peur
parce que j'étais j'ai cuisiné pour elle
car l'émission mais quid pitch était
fort king nerveuse quand vous voulez que
je cuisine pour denise bombardier vous
m'envoyez qu'a fait juste syrie à mettre
fin à ma carrière
et puis et puis c'est vrai que c'est
intimidant parce que je me suis dit je
remette les chances de battre des jeux
comme dead en studio puis à utiliser une
nouvelle faculté je peux aller la sa lu
et vu que je mange ou mambo participent
bonjour portait une casquette sur un
plateau de télévision jeudi soir
j'ai tout mis deux manches longues pour
pouvoir mais aussi une chance de fait
sur lequel elle avait pas aimer ton
pleut mais au final on m'a dit que s'il
s'avère un plat de lentilles ou ces
banques sont en bourgogne que ce serait
peut-être rester plus longtemps mais
après c'est la pole je fais dit de ne
pas refaire la sommellerie à la variété
des bulles pour le dit ma fille la vie
beaucoup trop courte pour voir des
bulles on boit que du champagne
il existe un aspect qui m'a tuer je sens
la correct wade de respecter puis de se
retrouver à frontières pas catégoriser
les jouis est-ce que je pense que
la seule chose qu'il faut garder en tête
maintenant c'est l'urgence climatique
oui effectivement mettons ce qui me dit
moi le samedi je me fais un steak je
mens comme tu fais ton steak le samedi
moi je vois ce que j'ai vraiment plus un
problème c'est dans la culture de manger
de la viande tout l'événement s'est
ternie que ce je te mentir mettons
souvent dans le discours de dans le
discours que tu viens d'avoir qui est
extrêmement nuancée de déserter tout le
monde en se respectant nous souvent ce
discours est un peu interpréter de la
façon de ces sexes et moi ap je vais
manger ma viande tout le temps oui ça
réfléchit comme là qu'une nuance
affaires en dit oui je comprends tout le
monde mangeait ce que vous voulez mais
soyez conscients quand même
qu'est ce que vous me mais serait-ce
qu'en même temps on va pouvoir expliquer
les roches comme si tout le temps parce
que toi tu aux carnivores que ça prend
dix mille litres d'eau pour faire un
livre est un cri vaut dix ans après
entre le double fond dames en fait c'est
déprimant et lui rend pas que la dame en
rouge il eut alors comment ça s'appelle
le livre j'ai comme oubliée le nom du
livre la fin de l'alimentation qui est
un livre allemand traduit en français
qui très intéressant qui montrent que
que tu sois viguen carnival prix que ce
soit oui un fact c'est justin mapp
hippies monde c'est qu'autant la culture
pendant un mois
comment c'est horrible pour les gens aux
taux commun mais mais que l'agriculture
plus à base de plantes à californie en
2d moment dévastateur jeudi les gens ne
sachent qu'ils n'ont plus d'eau pour
qu'on fasse du lait d'amande dans des
boîtes à 8 kg à saint lô où c'est celle
où se construit ce conseil la ligne fait
que c'est l'équipe en voici d'ailleurs
exactement ainsi luc foucault se
retrouve en plein milieu puis dire
qu'ils font manger moins de viande pour
attention à surf ou for peace est vrai
que c'est une urgence en même temps gk
un espèce de peut-être confiance stupide
depuis depuis que le monde est monde
qu'on voit la fin du monde qui sans rien
on a oui peut-être mais je me dis que au
final c'est fini tout va s'arranger
peut-être que j'ai une espèce de vision
utopique car tu mais en même temps la
vie trop courte pour que je passe toute
ma vie à part à neuilly serait-ce que la
fin du monde va la vie si j'avais ben
écoute je fais partie de l'histoire mais
c'est ce jeudi je pense que justin main
en se conscientisent assis en tant que
société surtout au canada
on fait vraiment des beaux efforts
comparativement au voisin se dit pour
pour réduire les co2 pour chemin moins
d'emballages mieux manger il ya encore
des efforts faits absolument mais des
jeux au moins le canadien moyen est au
courant de ce qui est affligeant mais je
pense que au moins on est conscient que
la robine existe qu'on essaie de faire
les cours déjà pour que ça eh ben pour
changer le plus de problème puisque près
de mentalité aussi tout ce qui est ancré
dans des générations ça a pris en tout
temps une coupe de génération afin
qu'ils pensent à d'autres choses mais je
pense qu'on va s'en sortir
je pense que déjà le tchèque commençait
cool là la jeune vingtaine commun qui
sont vraiment conscients de tout mais je
rencontre beaucoup de jeunes dans la
vingtaine sont allés skateboard ou par
la cuisine toutes ces filles ont
vraiment pas la même dit qu à mathon
culinaire que moi j'avais à l'époque où
sur l'écran j'ai beaucoup vient
exactement ce que je me dis mais les
autres peut-être paraître dans pas si
longtemps que ça va déjà mieux mais
quand leurs enfants vont être parents je
pense qu'on devrait être rendue tiens on
va aimer les sacs en plastique dans une
vie à vitesse que ça que ça augmente
c'est sûr que ça arrête
exponentiellement mauvaise qu'on sera
justement est ce que mes tantes eux dû
adapter son offre piétons les aidera
ceux qui te faisait pire
je dors avec le temps j'ai pensé que
j'évolue avec le public ce que je
faisais ya 15 ans quand j'ai commencé un
couscous etc temps mag un couscous etc
ce créneau ton fond du frigo moi je
trouve encore mais mais mais j'aime
penser que les récits at on appris
voluer avec le fil du temps j'aime
penser que le d'histoire que je te qui
m'a suivi depuis le début on appris
quelque chose c'est qu'ils sont capables
quand jésus aimait chasser encore la
philosophie c'est usines et avec des
produits d'épicerie puis cuisiner avec
le moins de vaisselle possible puis avec
des produits accessibles aux passants
mon but c'est pas de t'envoyer vers le
cultivateur biomasse de t'intéresser la
cuisine puis on fait ses intérêts sa
cuisine la paresse le ch est le livre de
bob le chef avant d'acheter le livre à
normand laprise à ma tante super jeu
tantôt dit on livre c'est le premier
livre de recettes qu'elle a mené si
c'est le premier livre c'est pas moi que
larcher c'est juste une mama tu me le
donner en cadeau
mes premiers de rester là mais quentin
d'avoir contribué à mon loyer
le premier en fait j'étais trop
puis à chaque fois qu'ils sortent et je
l'achetais pipeau vrai c'est en partie
parce que je me suis intéressé à cuisine
était d'être capable de vaincre et
inquiète ses recettes le sont vraiment
accessible pour moi qui étais un
adolescent qui s'intéressent un peu
assoupie une fois que je découvre ce que
tu découvres vraiment la base c'est pas
tout le monde qui le litige rallye ce
plu plus vieilles idées comme dieu c'est
la base ne recettes mettons le juste de
faire revenir un oignon petit on a aimé
ton de base n'est ce pas tout le monde
que ce réflexe là pour booster une chose
ou quoi que ce soit qui puisse aussi
c'est en partie grâce à grâce à bob
dechert 6 puis après ça ce que tu disais
par rapport au bio c'est qu'une fois que
tout cette porte le tour une boîte de
pandore lh2 d'irak et le ménage
cava de cuisine et maintenant je
m'intéresse à la qualité mais à l'image
et la qualité des êtres des aliments ça
fait toute la différence même espèce que
tu commences avec ce mot je trouves tu
pas une suite
je poursuis ton histoire je devais
prendre quelqu'un qui ne sait pas
cuisiner ou à peu près pas pu commencer
à essayer de l'intéressé à l'héliport la
forme le club pour 8 fait qu'avancer
qu'un produit puis aussi quand quand ses
cuisses des sharks cap mes pièces
c'était une liste d'épicerie en plus le
premier league
l'après midi je trouve alexis brutt fait
un excellent travail
c'est je l'est plus c'est mon père qui
est pas mal toute structure est passé le
mot j'ai fait les recettes
mais comme toute l'espèce de structures
que se livrent avec la liste d'épicerie
en début de livre permettait à voir la
bouffe pour une semaine complète visitez
vraiment bien budgété puis enfin la
semaine se respecter cette l'islam les
recettes qui était lié si je me rappelle
mon assistant deuxième seuil est elle à
ce même avant la paix rien qu'il ya un
des deux qui tiennent plus ou moins
heureux
[Rires]
mais le principe tout ça m'a appris le
gaspillage alimentaire oui dans les
maisons parce qu'il est arrivé avec une
épicerie puis à fantasmes ain't avait
utilisé tout fait mais dont je suis
forte en utilise la moitié dans une
recette
justement je penserai qu'à être
peut-être des jeux vouloir appliquer
comme les fleurs en deux temps de suisse
dames autant une recette bien souvent
dans ta vie de tous les jours quand j'y
repense pas se retrouve le chou-fleur
affrontons mon frigidaire puis noir
encore ce jour sur le site web
ces suies et maintenant la publication
durée certes c'est vraiment un site web
c'est moi qui cuisine chez nous et
achètent des affaires la fin noël j'ai
fait beaucoup d'affect baba même
échéance a acheté 2 litres de barber
j'ai pas vu la crise ont ils été mis aux
poubelles c'est très con vas clanche et
enfin 5 reims est ce que tu peux mettre
du babor dedans comme ceux qu on soit
l'acheter mais durant une coupe
d'options pour passer le reste de ton
truc puis aussi c'est quelque chose qui
dans les discos en quinze ans je faisais
le monde ne vaut plus le gaspillage
alimentaire comme à 20 le monde et le
monde ils veulent que les enfants soient
moins emballé possible j'ai compris à
mon âge j'ai même y aller d'un endroit
où ce que je peux acheter les produits
frais puis emmené mes propres sacs pipi
c'est moche la vie école qu'au début je
trouvais ce gamou oui vraiment je
revends d'épicerie je mettrais un sac
tkm
mais un stage en temps des enfants et
des règles bien ton sac chez vous prenez
sa table sur les sacs en plastique
utilisées mais il faut pas que ce soit
la seule à béquilles exactement mais
mais ce nom elle va mal d'être capable
de budget et une épicerie sur une
semaine ça m'a servi énormément encore
bien quand je retrouve mon friz qui
reste à faire rien pratiquement rien que
je mets dans le compost maintenant c'est
tout passe tout parce que c'est par
savoir cuisiner ça coûte pas mal moins
cher aux finances et capote énormément
puis les composts y avait une course
c'est comme la solution ultime dit mais
au moins on a l'option histoire de
fesses
c'est fou chez nous excuser énormément
avec des cdd
sb je devais moi je remplis bac à
compost une fois par semaine puis je
remplir un truc de récupération il faut
patiemment mais là les poubelles c'est
fou or un demi sac
c'est fou comment on jette enrayer ce
fait bien 10 cc cambrai en chinois
journées longues à cuisiner fait que oui
j'ai plus d'attendre le fait que le
monde qui travaille de 9 à 5 puis qui
arrive qu'on était chez leurs cadets
gardner reach cegos réelle telle mais on
a quand même tout les outils pour bien
c'est juste de s'organiser quand cuisine
mais j'accuse d'un stage et les petits
bacs à compost il tout à ce corps doit à
côté de toi
quatre étaient des trucs que je ne sais
quoi à ses côtés pour l'instant si ce
couac est captée et et journée dont un
des enfants exactement la question
vraiment on est connecté moi j'aime
beaucoup je serai beaucoup se développe
dans la sarthe
j'ai peut-être un projet de livre en
vain enfin vers 2020
que je fais avec des amis maintenant
vers où ça mène ce pas un livre de
recettes
c'est plus juste un livre sur ce qui me
tient à coeur le plus dans la cuisine
jeunes pops croquer
sinon c'est des trucs à un nouveau choc
samedi avec le m la kings samedi
barbecue
c'est un gars vraiment génial j'ai
vraiment retrouvé de travail étudiant
show avec lui sur un show sur plusieurs
épisodes
ouais enfin c'est au canal mon dieu je
dis le bon canal le canal est née puis
je pense que les premiers shows vont
être nombreux au mois de mai de tournai
ou non donc on commence dans parlons
bien fait dans ce sens que ça va être
ouais ce fait que j'ai su ce nobel était
sans vie fixer toutes les festivals je
traverse le québec en long et en large
jabbar su prouver c'est l'aspect de ma
job que j'aime le plus c'est de faire
des démonstrations de cuisine noir en
public dans les festivals j'aime ce
j'aime ce genre c'est que le monde
j'aime ce sens leur pouls c'est ce
qu'elles montrent comment on donne des
suggestions des fois meilleur cadeau
mais j'ai vraiment se passer c'est vrai
il ya du monde je pense qu' il aime pas
toute cette attention le mega man je me
pointe d'un festival c'est mon de façon
qu'à moi tant que je suis sur le site tu
peux me go c'est un coureur gamin ça me
fait tout à plaisir que le monde jazz
puis me parle de tout et de rien pour
réaliser tout de suite une coupe de
combat de chefs
bon c'est pas vous répondre que c'est
pas bon en vrac et on dévoile les
aliments qui est go away en fait je suis
je suis un très bon cuisine ligne je
suis heureux derrière les poêlons quand
soir 250 clients mais j'ai pas good
élaborer le menu musique du bois
je me suis développé son mauvais sens
sont démodés aussi se faire longtemps
que j'ai pas été fait quatre points
derrière les faux devrait rester en
autant que je mange beaucoup dans les
restaurants des fois en plus si je vois
qu'avec les textures de l'écart de
l'assiette a changé au fil des ans les
fois je pense au max absolue jean max
qu'est-ce qu'ils n'entrent cependant on
a beaucoup moins la bouffe qu'au début
des années 2000 au début des années 2000
si on préfère dacquois qui était haut
comme la tour de pise l'importance des
tamani dépit dans un filet mignon là
dessus du barman de la lettre de payer
sur des patins ils disent que je vais me
confond en tant que client est ce que ça
veux tu dis qu'il faut je mange tout cas
[Musique]
pour six tapis d'un instant c'est
beaucoup plus séparé de khambhat vie en
à trois endroits dans l'assiette une
couronne de fleurs des mini ddd point de
sot ce que coûte le connaît maintenant
c'est complètement différent d'eux mêmes
et je trouve ça beau je trouve ça
- ce qui est important c'est à
température de ce que je bouffe qu'au
final c'est bien cool fine crise de
belles assiettes mais ça arrive en
allemand mais frey est à votre air de
saint pierre s'est jamais aurait des
cookies to crash mais au moins qui était
à bonne température
mais c'est juin têtu un client qui
étoffent non non monsieur chiffres ils
ont réussi à tenir le coup et j'arrive
quelque part le service et l'ombre et
mèche je comprends ce que j'arrive au
départ j'ai commandé après groupe de
vins j'avais oublier q comment amazon
com se cuisine est ressorti les petites
d'urbain v
et puis même et c'est sous ce nom je
suis vraiment pas bon
justement à cette variété jamais que je
reprenne si c'est pas bon je perçois
quand on est juste passé mais en même
temps ça m'arrive vraiment romain de
points mais ce que je bouffe que je vois
tout à fait une crise
j'ai comme 4 restera là délicat c'est
pas tant mais c'est vrai je devais jouer
une place monge des sandwichs appel
slovénie charcuterie boucherie
puis ils font des sandwichs à
différentes viandes mais du prof mais
bof mais pas un mélange spécial ya cinq
sortes de viandes san luigi ne peut pas
manger de rock et oui je vais le depuis
je suis kid m'ont pas y habiter napoléon
et
jean laval fait que le week end saint
laurent fait l'épicerie puis si je
causais pas de troupes chez les éplucher
part ça je voudrais 1/2 sandridge sauver
ni abstrait liste dryades pommes puis ça
existe encore le souvenir et le dimanche
est fermée passer aux cours d'eau même
comme business et si jégou de sandwichs
à saucisses fumées le dimanche il y en a
à côté à vivre qui sont exactement
pareil mais j'irai jamais je me sens mal
c'est le slovenija qui nourrit en
saucisses d'activateur personne d'autre
jeudi plus fidèle aux slovènes yeux que
la plupart de mes blagues et c'est messi
c'est le nom que jalousie sauver nos
casques allocs j'ai pas eu d'effet 15
bouffe ça lui pis lentilles je vois un
ou deux j'ai deux restaurants de sushis
que je vais âgées mais jamais été outré
express assez des sushis de monsieur tri
cheveux sont super bons chiens que le
monde vont maigrir faut des essais mais
je n'ai rein pour la livraison
quand je m assois date gens mangent pas
plus que ceux des sushis mais ce soir il
aurait cinq restaurants sushi dans vie
c'est jean bouffe pas assez pour y aller
puis profiter de ces puissesseau fait
que je vais tout le monde souvent via
simon reste objets goût mais quand vient
dans des alliances rez-de-chaussée puis
je retourne tout à mes bons vieux ans et
jusque jeudi des pantoufles absolue
marché en plus s'il échappe un peu c'est
vrai que je ne sais plus je rate pas mal
pratiqué la star c'est quoi les c'est
quoi le mettant le monde qui viennent à
montréal
mise à part ceux qui viennent à mais là
c'est quoi les most pour quelqu'un qui
nous écoutent pas les nombres sont
absolument sûrs qu'elle rue c'est debout
sur ses incroyables ces gens ontario est
et a fait un scénariste je pense à ma
chaîne sport c'est on time warner si je
me trompe et que c'est incroyable c'est
entonné moussouris va un autodidacte de
la cuisine est prétérité hq lui est allé
cogner aux portes en france il a pris
des meilleurs il ya développé son propre
style sur plusieurs années et ramener à
montréal
ah oui moi je me suis je suivais sur
instagram à 20 qui ouvre son restaurant
et on est au prix sud mais milieu
caennais dublin comme un fake c'est vrai
que j'ai découvert et je me suis je dit
c'est donc ce qu'ils lui sont bio oui et
je me dis waouh c'est un style qui
n'existe pas à montréal
en même temps je me disais ça va ça va
ce qui fait écouter un resto de quartier
c'est la nouvelle génération de chefs
puis il fait les choses à sa façon des
produits est incroyablement bien
travaillé des techniques qu'on verra pas
il ya déjà fameux nu toutes basées sur
la couleur puis est capable de réussir
un tel exploit c'est ce ces malades
c'est pas le mettre sur papier ou un
pixel vici
c'est bien facile mais le feuilleton sur
une assiette move le tout est bon dans
ce bois en genre et en fait j'ai
peut-être j'ai décrit mark madoff a su
que je peux que marvel mais mais déjà
qui parle beaucoup de son resto sur ses
listes parce qu'une cuisine d'exception
puisqu'il prend aussi c'est que souvent
mais j'aime ce aller dans des
déplacements mais aussi comme l'europe
et par jérôme ferrari mais géré payer
ses classiques français pincer le monde
dit on d d d d d d des bouteilles d une
part à lyon puis
je veux des musiques présentes au mouzon
ces deux époques c'est anthony qui fait
la playlist cgpi s'est un peu l'époque
beaucoup de monde qui sont ces cookies
un restaurant prochainement la nouvelle
génération qui aime manger de la
nourriture gastronomique
ça tombait comme la ville a à offrir
est-ce qui est qui et qui est reconnue à
l'international et il commence sa fin et
sa basse ils gagnent plusieurs prix il
ya des cuisiniers
d'ailleurs on parle souvent des de
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre lui la chance
de voir une si bonne réputation que le
monde autour du monde venez travailler
pour pour le moose observé qui est
capable d'aller chercher les mercredis
pu offrir vraiment le maître du multi
sites comme de l'argent dépensé puis à
vanter avant de mourir tout mangé le
meilleur pote montréal afrique via la
vistule dispendieux beaucoup dans la
catégorie des restaurants dispendieux
c'est dispendieux abordable c'est ce que
à mathon le plan on va dire vrai chiffre
en temps tu prends le menu dégustation
pitié qui doit être à peu près 80 pièces
par personne fait que des cadres est une
pièce ma taxe petit petit à 110 places
mais avec surtout le menu dégustation
vin chaque service mais pour un autre 80
dollars
je sais même pas si j'ai conservé c'est
long c'est pas connaissance
qu'est ce que vous allez chacun payer
votre facture par la dgi pendant que ses
parents facture puis tu vas t'en tirer à
peu près de 2 100 piasses on ne dit pas
que de réalisme faut penser même moment
même je fais pas ça mon compte a dit
contraint m
mais c'est une expérience mais là il
faut que tu aimes les papilles ce tempo
l'époque comme j'ai pris ma musique
c'est cabaye est ce que est ce que ces
restos d'un mois six mois j'étais un fan
mettant des des émissions de haute
gastronomie des chefs des étoiles
michelin vise à faire là mais ça
m'intéresse le béton suivent les suivre
ces affaires le la cuisine moléculaire
ces trucs là malheureusement depuis que
je suis vegan j'ai pu vraiment la
possibilité d'aller danser place le tir
parce que même étrange et très près le
seul et une blouse que tu me parles de
1,8 service avec qui me coûte 200 pièces
à coups de barre de 20 c'est exactement
le genre d'activités que je ferai dans
un dans un événement spécial serait pas
ce béton pour aller super 1 mercredi
soir mais mettons ces mâts blanc sans
que ma blonde ou 6 mai c'est le que
check back ips et ce je trouve ce couple
justement quand je parle de nouvelle
génération argumente année au départ
qu'un veille le mousseau cet homme et
lui fixe soit en cuisine l'homme sort
alors est ce terme je pense même pas que
c'est juste pas d'alcool mais il s'est
rendu compte que une bonne partie de la
clientèle que justement il aimerait soir
un menu qui gagnent tout fait que annexé
sont restaurés les petits mousses au jeu
peu que ça devienne une infopub pour lui
mais les nouveaux chefs d'accusation ce
normal grand parc à moto-net com de
saint-martin
martin juneau pastaga des plots vigueur
et qui sont cuisinés de façon très haut
de gamme qui sont traités avec le même
respect qui va traiter c'est sur place
vous avez vous quelque chose d'effrayant
morisod et plus dit donne un side qui
ont grossi
c'est pourquoi l'expérience que je veux
dire je mets mes livres et nouveau chef
de la nouvelle génération les
schtroumpfs qui savent s'adapter le
mieux
juste à ma tei yvon auffret peu plus les
chefs c'est comme je disais tantôt nous
autres on essaye juste de tambov de tout
autre les crucifix on veut juste que
profiter le plus de monde profite de
notre forme dans le possible
fm justement on veut on veut le piston
dépenses mode soirée mousse quelque
chose je mets beaucoup de failles vj
pour un mois
c'est que ça change et comme empêchement
façon me nourrir de cuisine et ça me
forçait à travailler des légumes d'une
façon que je vais peut-être pas pensé à
les faire puis ça dit plus que quand les
légumes ville le mais notre action de
l'assiette serait pas juste la blanche
et puis le lait rissoler dans l'huile
d'olive c'est lui donner une forme en
boulettes fait craquer une frite fait
quelque chose c'est quelque chose qui se
passe avec tout cet animal puis je pense
que chemin de l'espèce de nouvelle
mouvance de plus jeune chef à barque
dans cette mouvance depuis assez
justement de varier leur menu puis c'est
se donner mais les games effet d'argent
a attiré le plus de gens vont sceller sa
soeur parce qu'ils viennent clairement
demande pour ce type si moi je suis
moche je suis pas légal je suivais j'ai
dis juste 0 le vg chien au coq ce soit
jo jamais été embêté par excès mais
d'art ur des restos où est-ce qu'ils
aient encore littéralement gentil
mettons j'arrive cannes les éléments qui
est qu'est-ce qui a pas de viande si
bien qu'ils en eau pour une affaire jeu
comme je peux insulter je peux peut-être
caché à personne mais je comme gaz
arriver à 2020 et c'est parce qu'il ya
une demande qui est là pis si vous
suivez peau et même d'allemagne qui ne
mentionne pas que ce soit celle que
j'aime c'est le plus jamais ça va
inciter quelqu'un qui province paris à
laurent
il ya des manies cathy aux épinards puis
harry 14 x et de la saison la ville est
sévère je voudrais les libraires sont
livrés à choisy-le-roi enac
j'ai aussi d'autres sages paroles comme
on met d'ailleurs mais c'est chaud je
trouve qu'à star on s'en va puis je
trouve les chefs la faune laisser jeune
chef le fond d'une belle approche parce
qu'ils font pas en prêchant ils font de
façon naturelle organique
c'est comme ça que ça devrait se passer
je pense puis du en question par rapport
à ça pour toi c c ou le pays dans le
monde
c'était le mieux manger ben c'est ta
fatigue c'est mal ajusté au mexique la
semaine passée - un projet qui était au
dessus dans un gta puebla qui
la région centrale de la cuisine
mexicaine en or et fluence encore de la
cuisine aztèque
c'est aussi le l'avion des estives de
chef de haute cuisine au mexique
c'est surprenant je pose exil et j'ai
mangé le mieux mais je veux dire qu'il
ya une couple d'années jeter le avec
mon ex copine et aux dépenses castille
je vois qu'à manger des instits tacos
toute la semaine et finalement ça m'a
ouvert les yeux sur une cuisine
absolument incroyable pips un groupé i
mexique fait que beaucoup d'influx ans
sa côte ouest mange beaucoup de fruits
de mer beaucoup de poissons c'est
vraiment un temps et centrale où ce qui
évolue quand tu manges beaucoup
d'insectes fériés - qui fit mouche pas
un gars je pouvais tu mens 3 1 j'ai mon
permis de conduire longueur je mange pas
ses terrasses et suspendent jacques
leget mes gosses ça gâche mon swing est
baby mama mia et le beau-frère boîte de
poids de chaque au milieu du bois toile
oui mais ceci de différent parce que je
m'envoie dans leur territoire fait que
je gagne bien ma vie ça me fait chier le
chemin j'étais au mexique je te plait
j'achete avec des chefs aussi aider des
vrais chefs cuisiniers locaux et me font
découvrir effectifs mais rarement
d'ouverture d'esprit même et je t'amène
que tu es j'ai vécu des plus belles
expériences culinaires par achetait
d'abord on tournait un espèce de série 2
un fait ça sans qu'un le podcast ça sort
dante est un mois aux aguets bond en
arrière
rien fait on le fait quand même
une série de prévention pour les gens
qui vont voyager pour faire du tourisme
gastronomique qui de plus en plus
populaire mais de prendre les
précautions nécessaires de voir les bons
vaccins avant de partir et rougemont
avec tout ce qui fait que dans mes bébés
a fait c'est important à faire parce que
ce temps vos dents dans un pays où les
moeurs curie noël ne sont pas comme ici
est une équipe comme fo sauf peut-être
passé et puis mes chiens déplace
vraiment traditionnels ou dimanche
d'état cause de la curatelle et à cause
de cervelle de veau servile sur un
marchant sur un coin de rue on se reçoit
cesson note-t-elle prend le vaccin manne
qu'ils soient pas malades des vacances à
chieti mais mais mais mais la nourriture
était combien exceptionnel et ce j'ai
vécu une des plus basses en faire ma vie
parce qu'on est appelée tourneur de
l'espèce de campagne est en plein dans
le en plein tournage le chef invité du
tournage et carrière on va l'aider je
nique mais par un plus qu'un nom ce
moment je fais on veut juste finir le
tournage de câbles ça coupe le vent du
tournage b-real pis c'est pas rien en
fait
ils y ont intérêt d'agriculture ils font
pousser du maïs et on passe le petit
déjeuner avec les employés de la terre
féconde et ge avec les agriculteurs puis
on bouffe un repas traditionnel mexicain
où il ya une espèce de ces cas majeurs
de gruau à base de maïs
puis il ya un panier des serviettes
chaudes des tacos y en a aux pommes de
terre il y en eu au cricket
puis la mère a fait des tortillas frais
sur une terre cuivrée une espèce de faux
en briques d'un milieu d'un champ qui
est gelée torti à frire et utilise la
culture exion de prendre son temps et
ses dires mais le son devient gary on
était tout près ces mails auraient tout
à 6,7
on mange là
à rebours de la gamme alfredo davanzo
tout s'est fait frais devant deux autres
on a apprécié le moment
pire on sait comme tout rendu compte
qu'on est apprise pourquoi de tourner
comme peut retourner
airbnb poids le t4 lights et puis à fin
du repas no joke le volcan s'est mis à
cracher de la bvk 1 puis en délire à
kerouac et des macarons michelin lyon en
battant et je pense que cette expérience
globale culinat elle le sait quand même
des affaires les plus hautes
posséder une leçon de vide comme des
fous tout juste prendre ton table et
c'est la vie mené son cause très
philosophique
j'ai trouvé ce char pour vivre avec eux
je vais casser quelque chose tu pars en
vacances ça n'arrivera probablement pas
d'aller dans un champ près milieu de
nulle part au pied d'un volcan manger
les tacos avec des nerfs que tu que ya
très peu d insectes pic c'est bon au
final on le sait ça ça a été mais sinon
dans les pays que j'ai vraiment aimé la
nourriture j'ai bien aimé la nourriture
portugal justement espèce de diète
végétarienne j'aime manger des sardines
dans un tracteur pour portugal puis
encore une fois c'était comme un enfant
et spirituelle peugeot revenus de
placement et genève
merci à fatima pierre valat gilles
manger des sardines et puis je le suis
il était tellement bonne que j'ai
recommencé à smocks le temps de me
remettre de ça comme troisième échec à
mennecy stadistes bones et redire je
veux le mâle paula et l'expérience de la
vie
[Rires]
j'avais mosquée du palais tantôt
découvrir le plaisir de voir prendre son
temps à manger je fais d'envoyer
aujourd'hui au liban camille zammit lépi
qui libanais puis tout tournait autour
de la bouffe
si c'est comme on se levait l'on avait
ôté on se prépare et de quoi manger puis
on mangera des restos petit on va on
prenait le temps s'asseoir manger
longtemps essayé d idées menu pitié
pendant ce temps leurs échanges les
glissements un petit suivi quelque chose
ensemble
mais la pression de démarrage est en
fait une activité puisse pas long qu'on
passait des jeux après éventuellement
faudra qu'on consulte puis le après ses
deux titres assaut après c'était parti
pour une coupe d'or chacun veut juste un
voyage à prendre le temps de manger avec
du monde à goûter les enfants hermans et
tellement on est en train de manger ça
après celle ci qui je vais faire soupire
t elle est peut-être passé parce que je
tournais fermer sa g valores prend le
temps manger mambé des mers chaudes de
cuisine qui était fait c'est charles
antoine gratton qui
le restaurant la plage les jeunes chefs
aux cordes d'argent mais lui faisait une
émission à tv5 qui s'appelait à table
avec l'ennemi où il prenait déjà deux
cultures différentes pied forcé à
s'asseoir autour d'une table et de
discuter autour d'eux des plats et les
gens étaient rapidement leurs
différences de côté à découvrir la
nourriture de l'autre culture ou et
c'est à complètement génial je pense que
pour des raisons d'assurance puis il y
avait eu comme étant un pays du moyen de
réhabiliter de sam sarr est tourné
quelque part quelque chose de violent
arrivé sur scène juste ira plug sur ses
missions le mail c'était un émission
vraiment émission vraiment intéressante
le qui prouvaient kamal qu'il ya quelque
chose de rare leur nourriture à sable
oui oui exact tu vois c'est une des
recommandations mais tout nouveau guide
canadien c'est prenez le temps de manger
puis mangé avec des gens oui bah moi je
découvre toutes les pays de ce jeu par
un but de tout inclus chemin tout
compris de ma vie puis même qu'en voyage
avec fiston
on essaie de tracer de l'année vive la
vraie expérience puis de montrer que les
gentils c'est à cuba puis rémy s'ils
marchent plus longtemps ça oui parce que
c'est la ja culture maintenant c'est
tellement définissent appartement par
les labos comprendre une culture sans
avoir goûté c'est fait c'est quelque
chose qui tout le monde ferme à trois
fois par jour mais que tout le monde
fait tout le temps biden on a une belle
au québec il faut la foule a partagé il
faut faut pas rentrer en héros il faut
pas vendre la piscine faut pas compte du
ragoût de pattes de
ragoût de boulettes et puis la torture
et puis j'ai tellement content je te
demande de voir parfois tout retirer
parce que mes charmes du lac-saint-jean
l'amener à 1082 vient pas toujours et
bush ces plaques en grandes banques en
parle mais il ya une question qui me
tracassait depuis tantôt on est le prête
à me tracasse pas pantoute nommé ses
titres attendus décacheté gêne les y
avait des tiger woods aurait stoppé les
c'est valorisant c'est quoi même les
plus grands excès si tu disais le genre
qui est débile les quatorze mille
piastres c'est quoi une fois que tu via
des réseaux que tessa potes de six de
bronze intel qui vient pas qu'ils
commentaient la fin quand les bruins de
boston ont gagné la coupe stanley le
couple d'années il ya une photo qui
circulait sur les réseaux sociaux dans
le fond c'était le club payait c'est en
reste au beau fixe et souper l'appui la
soirée s'est tiré après en partie puis
c'était sept cent mille pièces iommi
c'est la carte de crédit du club qui
payait sa place et donc tout le monde
qui rend demandons évidemment tout le
monde j'imagine qu'il y avait l'équipe
l'entourage des joueurs les amis la
blonde il devait par monsieur madame
tout le monde pouvait rentrer en balles
mais c'est open bar open golf open tout
ce que vous voulez pour tout le monde
qu'il embrumé la forte que je sais pas
ça ce camp à madrid passe mais le monde
qui vont se rendre jusqu'au bout
un bon petit cadeau pour mon dos on a
passé en ce podcast des films et aux 780
boulevard taschereau
dans un certains restaurants très haut
de gamme avec des propriétés soumises
investisseurs semi douteuses ont en
effet comme le super des full patch de
certains groupes de motards ou sont
énervés que leur patch puis bigon comme
dans des barquettes comme à côté du
gopio puis le reste étant réservé juste
à un meeting annuel de gros basse puis
avait laissée errer la céleste avait
acheté des forfaits supporter que à tout
tout les serveuse du restaurant et mais
comme des week-ends à l'alaska malade il
y avait des pensées vous dépensez dollar
gbp de l'alcool aux cuisines tout puis
et puis je sais que épices cumin
tu devrais pas facile mais quand jean 22
ans puis tu travailles dans le reste où
tu voulais travailler puis aussi je
mentirais dick afin de changer mimétique
s'arrêterait ces années et j'avais je
sors de relire mes collègues europe ce
qui ne rend pas malade
ben c'est c'était quelque chose puis les
bills la libye est élevé très de dali
car on met de l'ordre et ça paye cash
est excédée parce qu'un policier quand
bébé un gâchis littéralement en dessous
la table que j'allais succès
ap a passé des choses que j'avais
beaucoup dans mon jeune temps précis
année ça c'est bâle après c'est sa
marque et l'imaginant - il s'en passe
des enfants pour jaime est un enjeu pour
nos plongeurs là par leurs débuts du
podcast mais c'est comme si on est seul
monde un seul monde animal les stades
parce que home is tautavel animalerie
shepard au bord des rues people je
tairai le nom de mr l'animalerie j'ai
pas trop merci infiniment
c'est un plaisir pour les élections
conversation évidemment bénéficié de
coups puis et c'est un milieu que les
gens à gasquet n'est ce pas tant que ça
s'il ya des rentrées d'ailleurs un petit
peu le double à moi ça me fait tout un
plaisir de partager ce genre de com ggc
tout derrière puis je me rends compte à
quel point chanceux
ouais c'est ça tu es chedid jacques latu
mais non j'essaie justement d'aligner
d'enligner monfils pipier côté il va
sûrement faire ses propres gaffe tu
m'aimes pas je t'aime avec l'expérience
de vic juge aussi de moins paniqués de
paniquer le moins possible mais
maintenant partie des gros problèmes si
la qualité des bouteilles
j'aimerais que j'aime juste les
bouteilles à pizza hut que je vois ce qu
est ce qu ont invité le monde qui sont
ici dans le podcast a même suivi - c'est
sûr pour les recettes bob le chef points
car on essaye de faire des vidéos
youtube ou siméon j'ai un manque de
rigueur c'est vraiment j'ai un grand
respect pour youtube heures qui sont
capables d'en faire deux trois quatre
vidéos par semaine j'ai pas le temps de
le faire
j'ai moins l'énergie aussi de faire avec
un j dida mis de temps à temps on fait
encore des vidéos sur youtube des fonds
et encore live sur twitter
mais pour me josée le instagram bob le
chef c'est la meilleure plateforme
littéralement je suis tout le temps en
train de regarder les photos
procrastiner l'appui je réponds vraiment
vraiment à tout le monde qui m'écrit je
prends le temps de répondre je trouve ça
important pour ouvrir le monde ils
prennent le top c'est vraiment moins
qu'estimé crise reste à g le ses succès
- qui va répondre
absolument très cool pierre merci merci
énormément a besoin c'est très plaisante
et ça c'est ainsi